i know your pain i know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen
from us it was a landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now donald
trump's response to last week's attack
on the u.s capitol led
twitter to permanently ban him from its
platform and facebook and youtube closed
his account
on the grounds that he had used their
platforms to incite violence
next apple and google banned the twitter
competitor parlor from its app stores on
the grounds that the perpetrators of
last week's attack used it to coordinate
and because the service doesn't engage
in adequate content moderation
then amazon which owns about a third of
the global cloud storage market
evicted parlor from its cloud hosting
service taking the site down
entirely these decisions drew a
ferocious reaction
both for and against from people of all
political stripes
for better or worse as edward snowden
put it after trump was kicked off
twitter
this will be remembered as a turning
point in the battle for control over
digital speech
it is stunning to watch now as every war
on terror rhetorical tactic to justify
civil liberties erosions
is now being invoked in the name of
combating trumpism
wrote glenn greenwald so how should
those who value
a free and open society feel about the
deplatforming of the commander-in-chief
the ongoing purge of many of his
supporters and repression of discussion
of 2020
election voter fraud claims twitter is a
private company
and ceo jack dorsey's capacity to evict
even the president of the united states
is something worth valuing but what if
the network
power of a handful of silicon valley
giants is so great
that there's nowhere else to turn and
are facebook twitter and google acting
independently
or bending to the will of congress at a
time when tech has been so deeply
politicized
the takeaway from the great d
platforming of 2021
is that we need now more than ever an
open digital commons where
individuals can maintain ownership of
their own identities
and speech is highly resistant to
political pressure
decentralized networks are vital to
protecting open discourse not only from
twitter facebook and google
but from ted cruz joe biden josh hawley
or kamala harris which is where the real
power lies to stomp on the free speech
rights of american citizens
it's easy to forget that not long ago
twitter's jack dorsey and
facebook's mark zuckerberg embraced the
concept of a neutral public square
we do not want to become the arbiters of
truth
the shift from digital commons to
actively curated news feed was underway
long before the election in october of
2020
facebook deranked and twitter blocked
the sharing of a new york post story
claiming that joe biden met with an
executive at a ukrainian gas company
where his son held a board seat
twitter also blocked the nation's oldest
newspaper from using its account for
more than two weeks
when the new york times kara swisher
grilled parlor ceo john matsey about
parlor's role in inciting the capital
breach
he defended its hands-off approach if it
was organized on your site what should
happen on your site
look if it was illegally organized and
against the law and what they were doing
they would have gotten it taken down but
i don't feel responsible for any of this
and neither should the platform
considering we're a neutral town square
the handful of companies that own the
dominant share of social media
and the underlying infrastructure of the
internet disagree
and have made it increasingly difficult
for parlor to operate
but the most dangerous threat isn't
coming from silicon valley
to get what they want from tech ceos
both republicans
and democrats have regularly threatened
to strip away the liability protections
provided by section 230 of the
communications and decency act
which is known as the internet's first
amendment through the effect of section
230 a special immunity from liability
that nobody else gets
congress has given big tech in effect a
subsidy
that's a pretty foundational law of the
modern nature
exactly right it should be revoked
democrats want to leverage section 230
to force them to weed out misinformation
which they falsely imagine can be sorted
out by panels of accredited experts
or finely tuned algorithms republicans
have threatened to repeal 230 unless
platforms commit to viewpoint neutrality
a standard which stanford technologist
daphne keller
says is impossible to uphold i don't
even know what being neutral would mean
would it mean
allowing every single thing to be
uploaded and just showing it in
chronological order
can you be neutral if you have search
features can you be
neutral if you allow people
to mute things i think
a truly neutral meaning showing
everything that is
legal social media platform would be
full of content that most users don't
want to see
president-elect biden is making a public
push for a new domestic terrorism law
and red flag laws which would make it
easier for federal agents to seize
firearms based on a user's online posts
perhaps americans way of thinking about
free speech is not the best way
wrote emily bazelon in the new york
times magazine at the very least we
should understand
that it isn't the only way and that
european speech regulations
have created better conditions for their
citizenry to sort out what's true from
what's not and to make informed
decisions
about what they want their societies to
be but in the eu
these regulations have created
unintended consequences of flagging
content that's disturbing yet vital to
the public interest
such as an archive of syrian war crimes
wrongly flagged as
terrorist content under the eu
guidelines right now
we don't have any clear information
telling us
that taking down all of these videos
really is making us safer
in fact a lot of people who are expert
researchers on security
are concerned that this will effectively
drive more people
into darker corners of the internet into
echo chambers where they only ever hear
from people who
agree with a violent agenda what do you
think when people are saying it's time
for civil war i'm bringing my guns to
washington
you think you just let them say that
well if it was up to me we wouldn't be
in this situation sides hate each other
here we find ourselves
whether or not it's parlor it's twitter
it's facebook it's google it's telegram
whatsapp whatever it might be
you can't stop people and change their
opinions by force by censoring them
they'll just go somewhere else and do it
a study from social psychologist richard
rogers found that a robust network of
d-platform figures
has already emerged over the past
several years on encrypted apps like
telegram
the preferred platform for pro-democracy
activists in hong kong trying
to avoid chinese censorship a transition
to a new more decentralized and private
web
may be accelerating as privacy-centric
duckduckgo
has experienced significant growth in
search as a google alternative
and the encrypted messaging app signal
saw a big bump after elon musk
encouraged the masses to install it
with a crackdown in progress and likely
to intensify
once a new congress and president take
office we should focus instead on
enhancing encrypted communication
platforms that make online speech
harder to control and resisting law
enforcement efforts to weaken
vital tools like end-to-end encryption
there's a lot that still needs building
to create an alternative digital commons
but it can be accomplished communicating
freely
might take more work in the future and
your favorite politician might get
banned or your favorite app taken out of
the store but in this
cat and mouse game the mice far
outnumber the cats
that said in the short term the decision
makers at twitter and facebook may want
to consider that repression tends to
have the unfortunate effect of pushing
legitimate dissidence
and dangerous unsavory extremists into
the same channels
sigmund freud theorized that when
thoughts or experiences are repressed
they inevitably resurface
in more deranged and damaging forms when
our dominant communication platforms
seek to repress
widely held beliefs and opinions those
beliefs and opinions aren't likely to
simply disappear
but rather re-emerge elsewhere in less
visible forms where they'll face
less scrutiny the next few years may be
ugly but
silencing dissenters will ultimately
fail information wants to be
free as stuart brand famously quipped
the great repression will almost
certainly have unintended consequences
but it can't last forever
you